we wanted to announce that our website
is going live in
several different languages and we did
this because we want to be able to reach
as many guests as we can
and provide that great guest service in
as many languages as possible so all of
our guests feel
comfortable when they come here before
they come here throughout their
experience and when they're learning
more about our property yeah we
definitely wanted to make it more
user-friendly
accessible to the masses no matter where
they're coming from
it is extremely user-friendly very easy
there's a drop down arrow at the top of
the website
and all you have to do is select your
language and you can visit
every different page of our new website
in your own language so if you want to
learn about the rides in the adventure
dome
our new ride nebula z everything going
on up there
if you want to book a hotel room in your
own language
every aspect of our property you can
visit every different page on that
website
we have a new ride in the adventure dome
i'm sure a lot of people have heard
about nebula
z that's very exciting we also have a
food court coming soon
early summer that's going to be a great
addition to the property